depending on what part where you are
yeah what part of the country you are if
it was a trump rally it would kill
you think so yeah we love lieutenant dan
i love that movie but i would even call
lieutenant wang okay there we go yeah
right lieutenant wang right what could
be a possibly safe version of that is
you came out in a wheelchair but you
just put
green screen on your legs so people know
that you're not really no no
the whole trick though is to fool the
audience yeah the artist
the artist yeah these are just ideas
that i have
in my little mind sometimes they won't
be executed
you know really does hurt me though when
people say that i'm dumb
on twitter people say that what is the
one constant insult you've heard your
entire life
joking or dumb so that's why that's one
yeah shafir used to do it all the time
that you're dumb you never read a book
and just tease me and it's like it
sounds like trauma
you think it is yeah of course and it
used to feed into something and i'm like
maybe i am dumb
i don't think that i am i think that you
have a different kind of intelligence
than me
i love when people say that i love when
people say but it's that's true right
like traditional classroom
intelligence is not a gauge for
so like it doesn't speak to so many
other kinds of intelligence
well when i like when i was in a junior
high not junior high when i was in uh
community college junior high community
college right college
yeah yeah you get it and um you know i
i the first i only did a semester but
the first
semester the only good grades i got was
in philosophy because i care i
for some reason i was so depressed right
that i would just kind of dive into like
philosophical ideas you know what i mean
and you know just existentialism or or
whatever
and whatnot and i used to like you know
if i if my interest is in something
right i'm full i think so yeah you know
what i mean but if i'm not interested in
something
it just just kind of enters my brain and
leaves you know
yeah i don't have like i don't absorb
things i think that you like star trek
next generation i'll absorb every
information into it yeah yeah star wars
sort of information that's how you can
tell what he truly cares about or you
have interest
because he has like a really good
retention for certain details and like
really specific things like even
people's names but then
um for other things absolutely like his
his brain is wiped clean off of that
information like he doesn't retain
any of it at all i can't retain it um
so it hurts me when i have to tell him
like my life story for the eighth time
yeah kalala you're different i feel like
you
almost retain a little bit of everything
yeah that's right
like i'm kind of an absorber on where
it's like i don't need to be actively
listening
for me to for it to be downloaded into
my hard drive
like somehow like if it if i happen to
see it
uh it'll be tucked somewhere and i can
retrieve it when i need to
but um that's not a good thing
it's not because you in life in order to
be somebody who can
you know like have things roll off your
shoulders you need to have the memory of
a goldfish
i forget like i don't forget pains and
aches like things that hurt me people
have hurt me like
these things like are very fresh in my
mind like i want to be like my
my stepdad roger i he has like a seven
seven memory seven second memory like
you could you could
get into like a cuss match with him and
then seven seconds later he'd be like do
you want some coffee sweetie like he
just has a little memory
no he doesn't he's just always been that
way like he doesn't have a very
um you know he doesn't retain a lot yeah
like i'll memorize how many fish
jean-luc picard has
in the tank behind him crazy right in an
episode
i go oh yeah that's two in this episode
right like i'll memorize
little things on people in the
background of movies and tv
shows right but then there's certain
things that just like i don't
know especially like when it comes to
science or something like that i just
don't get it
yeah or mathematics mathematics how far
um did you ever take math in college
palomino well i don't even understand it
what i do
the only way i can do it is like stardew
valley
so this is how i count so what i'll do
is um
on my farm you get these pigs
and the pigs they they release truffles
right and sporadic you don't know you
know what i mean so what i'll do is i
won't count the truffles that they've
so dumb oh this is good yeah they're not
dumb
yeah you're not dumb bobby
i won't i i won't count how many i pick
up right and i also i won't comment
count how many i have in the chest in
one of my
sheds right so what i'll do is i'll just
pick them all up
pick up and then pick up all the all
ones in the in the in the in the chest
and then to put them in the um the the
truffle maker machine
right i so i have 30 truffle makeup
machines
you're 30 yeah that's a bit much so so
i'll have to work
to get these to get the truffle maker
machine you have to make them
and each one is very difficult to make
you got to get
slime right classic and it's either you
have to farm them
in in in mines or you have to build a
slime farm which i'm not gonna do i
don't have enough [ __ ] room on my
[ __ ] farm for a slime farm is the
only space you have to take
up for that i don't know too much about
slime babe but i trust
right you need and then here's the
here's the proponent
that this is very difficult to get not
just wood
you have to get hardwood okay and
hardwood
you can only get that [ __ ] two ways
three ways hardwood you can only get it
from the secret
forest that's the main way right which
is far away
yeah if they usually will run there it
takes all day
no fast travel later in in the game you
can
create um these spheres or these podiums
where you can fast travel to places
you sound like an engineer to me that's
all [ __ ] you all right
does this slime naturally occur or are
there like hagfish
that prod in the water that produces
slime that you then harvest
the the slime is from the slime
creatures
like hack fish yeah but they're in um
they're like little balls and they have
little faces
yeah yeah wait no hag fish look like
they're fish but they're like little
eels actually no these are balls
baby i don't like those well it's fine
it's the way the [ __ ] game to the
maker
yeah they're like little blobby balls
right and they attack you you've played
it oh yeah you know
yeah yeah do you you know about it then
yep right so um they're cute
right yeah but when they get angry
sometimes they change color and they
they vibrate a little bit different
and then there's slimes with little um
um
yellow tentacles they're rare yeah and
they're black
and if you kill one of those you'll get
like shoes
or like some sort of like um a weapon
okay wow
that'd be nice if we could hunt and then
when you kill an animal it's not just
the meat but you get
a golden goose yeah yeah yeah the new
slides you know i mean the spring
edition
that'd be nice or montclair jacket
that's nice
thanks yeah um so how far did you get
did you ever get to the desert
um yeah i think that's as far as i got
the desert that's up north
west yeah yeah thank you for exactly so
the desert
has the best mind there right and it's
um
there's also these um all kinds of
little creatures
in there but um they're hard to make so
anyway that's how i can count
hey guys we're gonna take a really quick
break to share some of our like
favorite sponsors with you